estamos en nuestro módulo de inducción
derivada y este módulo fue aportado por
ben y ter y es un módulo bastante
interesante lo interesante aquí es
conceptualizar la idea de la que es la
derivada y recuerden que la derivada la
habíamos definido como la recta tangente
en cualquier punto de nuestra gráfica de
hecho en este ejercicio vamos a tomar la
función f x igualados x cúbica esto de
aquí es la función 2x cúbica y yo lo que
voy a querer hacer o la idea que está
detrás de este módulo es jugar con los
puntos de anaranjado dese cuenta que
cuando yo pongo el puntero encima de uno
de los puntos de anaranjado hay una
recta abajo o arriba que me cambia de
color
la idea quiere subir a este punto o
bajar este punto de tal manera que
cambie la pendiente de esta recta si se
dan cuenta en este momento tenemos la
recta con pendiente cero pero esta recta
va a ser una recta muy especial es muy
recta tangente a este punto en mi curva
y como están gente no puede ser cero yo
estoy segurísimo que no es cero por lo
tanto voy a mover un punto hacia arriba
de tal manera que a mi parecer esta
recta quede tan
a mi función 2x cúbica y de hecho ya
está yo creo que por aquí es la recta
tangente y si se dan cuenta mientras yo
me voy moviendo este punto amarillo la
derivada con respecto a x de mi función
evaluada en menos 2 va cambiando de
hecho en este caso cuando yo digo que ya
tengo mi recta tangente o
aproximadamente ya tengo mi recta
tangente la derivada con respecto a x de
mi función es valor de menos dos me da
24 es decir que la pendiente de mi recta
tangente es igual a 24 ok y ahora
juguemos con la otra línea también es
positiva es una pendiente muy grande y
es casi entre 14 y 15 yo creo que está
más o menos por aquí bien ahora tomaré
el siguiente punto y también jugar es
también positiva
no es tan grande la pendiente pre oscar
cercana al 5 va a ser por aquí aquí pues
se dan cuenta ya es la recta tangente la
pendiente vale 0 de hecho este es un
punto de inflexión por lo tanto la
pendiente tiene que valer 0 ya no hay
que moverle nada aquí la derivada de f
en 0 es igual a 0 y ustedes lo pueden
comprobar también derivando
2x cúbica si se dan cuenta la pendiente
en este punto es una pendiente plana no
aumentó ni disminuyó bien ahora vamos
con el siguiente punto con el siguiente
punto la pendiente también va a ir
aumentando va a aumentar y es muy
cercana a 5 otra vez de hecho se dan
cuenta en los primeros puntos nuestra
pendiente y va aunque esté decreciendo
era siempre positiva pero iba
decreciendo hasta volverse plana y ahora
lo que va a pasar es que la pendiente
está creciendo otra vez en este punto va
a crecer de nuevo bastante hasta llegar
casi al 14 por aquí bien y ahora va a
volver a crecer un pendiente es positiva
otra vez de en todos han sido positivas
excepto en el 0 y en los últimos puntos
muy pendientes ha aumentado y ahí está
si ustedes se dan cuenta y hacen bien el
ejercicio van a obtener la gráfica de la
derivada original dadas las pendientes
no sean exactas pero si más o menos
tienen una idea de cómo son estos
pendientes entonces van a ir obteniendo
la gráfica de la derivada original al
mover los puntos de color naranja
obtuvimos más
el bosquejo de cómo tenía que ser la
gráfica de derivadas y ya con la gráfica
de la función derivada nos podemos dar
cuenta que aunque no teníamos el punto
de al menos punto 5 la pendiente de la
recta tangente va a estar cerca del 2.5
más o menos por aquí o por ejemplo si
nosotros tomamos el punto menos 2.5
hasta acá la pendiente alargue está
tangente en mi función asociada ese
punto tendría que ser cercano a 30 muy
aproximado a 30 y si se dan cuenta con
la solución de este módulo ya obtenemos
la pendiente de la recta tangente para
cualquier punto que se nos ocurra y ya
con esto acabamos nuestro módulo que
espero que les haya sido muy
clarificador